hey what is up guys I'm Kip EHD here and
this is the phone that a lot of people
have been talking about recently this is
the Moto X it's the first phone at the
collaboration directly between Google
and Motorola since Google bought
Motorola Mobility more than a year ago
so we expected big things out of this
phone and now it's time to give it the
full review treatment so how'd any
further ado let's take a closer look at
the Moto X so yeah this device is
different it's really different in a lot
of ways from the competitors and a lot
of these differences come from Motorola
taking bets on what the average consumer
wants on a phone not a geek
I'm hate a video explaining this not too
long ago it'll be the first link right
below that like button on this video but
from my perspective a geeks perspective
actually giving the phone a chance this
phone really impressed me in a lot of
ways first of all the design this phone
is a really subtle compact handsome
design for a phone motorola basically
decided that a phone with a rounded back
is easier to hold so they built it
around that and they built what i think
is one of the nicest curves in any phone
out there much better to hold than what
we saw attempted in the Samsung Galaxy
Nexus
so the Moto X has a curved back and it
fits well in the hand and it's actually
has a stacked battery inside to take up
all that space we'll get to the battery
in a second but basically this bone is
packed to the gills with the internals
the storage is not expandable it uses a
nano SIM instead of a regular Micro SIM
it's crazy but the phone feels super
solid oh and it also helps that this
phone has a rubberized back so it's not
velocity plastic like the galaxy s4 but
it's also not solid metal like the HTC
One so it's a nice sweet spot right in
between and I like it it also has a
dimple right in the middle of the back
and I just really like it for some
reason I'm not sure why but I'm glad is
there and again that soft touch back is
just a great feel for anything handheld
the one thing I don't like about the
outside is the headphone jack being up
on the top but that's really a minor
complaint just a preference but
alongside that headphone jack you will
find a microphone and you'll find
another microphone in the chin of the
phone and yet another one on the back so
this phone has three microphones
essentially for noise cancellation to be
able to isolate voices which it'll need
now inside the Moto X is the reason why
a lot of spec heads have a hard time
wrapping their head around this phone so
check this out it's essentially rocking
multiple CPUs some of which
are dedicated to certain tasks all in
order to optimize battery life they call
it the x8 system and they're made up of
the dual core main processor a version
of the 1.7 gigahertz Snapdragon s4 pro
then it has the quad core Adreno 320 GPU
for graphics and a dedicated core for
contextual computing and gesture
recognition and another dedicated core
for natural language processing and
voice recognition that makes 8 cores in
this phone all handling their own power
states to optimize different things so
how does the performance end up pretty
damn well actually it's scary good it
might not benchmark like a boss but I
can guarantee you it feels and performs
like one every day of the week it
handles multitasking well handles
scrolling well it happens opening and
closing apps well very quick it actually
handles web browsing exceptionally well
in fact this and the new Nexus 7 were
the only devices that really glide
through Google Chrome on any site I
throw at it
Google Chrome has been notoriously a
power sucker and can lag on a lot of
these high-end devices but it's crazy
when you think about it this device is
one of the smoothest of them all there's
never any stuttering or lag in the UI
like you might see in TouchWiz or HTC
Sense and overall this phone has been
buttery smooth every second since I
first got it which is really impressive
I can't say the same about stuff like
the Samsung Galaxy s4 and a lot of this
has to do with the fact that number one
this is very close to vanilla Android
and number two this is a 720p display so
this moto X is rocking a 1280 by 720
Super AMOLED display which means it has
way less pixels to push around than a
1080p display and the GPU doesn't have
to work nearly as hard but is this bad
for the viewing experience
short answer nope in fact take it from
me someone who absolutely loves
resolution and high pixel density the
only time I can see a difference between
this and a 1080p display of the same
size like the HTC One is when you put
them side-by-side right next to each
other and the average person is never
going to do that the average person is
never going to spot a pixel on this
display it comes in at 316 pixels per
inch right in line with the iPhone 5 and
has a very bright saturated colors
thanks to that AMOLED display nice
contrast nice viewing angles and
everything it was a little bit warm in
color temperature and I would have liked
it to be a little bit more act
but then again that's what you expect
from an AMOLED display and you can
really only tell the difference when
you're holding it next to an IPS display
so yeah I would say the trade-off
Motorola made here was a good move as
the display still looks tax sharp to my
eyes and the frame rates are through the
roof when compared to other 1080p phones
also the Moto X takes advantage of that
AMOLED display with its unique
Notification peak system so when your
phone is not in use and it's facing up
like on your lap or on a table
it sort of breathes the Notification
peak in and out and when you want to
check it you just tap and hold and you
can read your latest notification up top
all of the rest of your notifications
will be shown down below and you can
swipe down to unlock and get to those
anytime you get a new notification it'll
take over the top window so you can peek
that I kind of wish I was able to peek
at more than one notification at once
but for now it's just the newest one one
at a time now if any other smartphone
without an AMOLED display I attempted to
do this kind of thing it would burn
through the battery life super fast
since that is an AMOLED display these
thin white characters you see are the
only pixels being lit so the rest of the
display is still off so it really
doesn't take much power at all now I
mentioned earlier that there is a
dedicated cord just for natural language
processing on the Moto X and that
actually brings us to one of my favorite
features on the Moto X and even if it's
not a feature that people are going to
use all the time I think it's going to
impress a lot of people and when a lot
of people start to get to use this
they're not going to want to go to
another phone that doesn't have this and
that is the ability to speak to your
phone and have it give you answers and
perform actions without you even
touching it or waking it so the Moto X
can be completely asleep and I can go
you want to say I want to ask for the
weather and I just want to know what the
weather is outside I can just say okay
Google now what's the weather outside
now there's a little bit of a delay
before it gives me the weather that's
because it actually needs to finish
listening and then wake up the Google
now service and then punch in all the
information and then search it and then
deliver the answer so there's a little
bit of a process so it may not seem as
natural and quick to just ask the phone
a question have it immediately deliver
answer as if it was already awake but it
is a cool feature and I think a lot of
people are gonna like it
ok Google now how tall is the Empire
State Building
our State Building is 1,000 so there's
another one of those things that most
phones would chomp through battery if
they tried since they'd be activating
all of their cores to pull it off the
Moto X like we said has a dedicated
low-power chip just for this kind of
stuff it also recognizes your voice from
when you first set it up and it actually
does a really great job thanks to all
those microphones of rejecting other
noise and isolating your voice and not
responding to other people who don't
sound like you but anyway speaking of
battery life since clearly Motorola made
in a lot of decisions just for the
battery life the x8 chip the 720p
display turns out the battery life is
really good now motorola claims 24 hours
of battery life maybe a lighter user
could get that out of it but I didn't
but I still got an absurd number closer
to 14 to 16 hours of battery life out of
this phone you really have to be using
it all day to kill it and it is most
certainly a longer-lasting phone than
the galaxy s4 or the HTC One and the
remarkable thing is this isn't even a
huge battery physically it's actually
smaller than those other phones it's a
2200 milliamp hour battery but you know
motorola knows battery and that's the
thing they've had a lot of experience
with it they made the Droid RAZR MAXX
I am very very pleased with the battery
life in the Moto X especially
considering its size and of course on
the back of the Moto X you also have
your camera and on the back what we're
looking at here is a 10 megapixel sensor
and a single LED flash but more about
the sensor it's what they call a clear
pixel sensor and Motorola has never been
really good with cameras shall we say I
mean they don't exactly have the highest
end camera phones on the market I was
expecting this to be a little bit
different but I'll just go ahead and
tell you now it is not a good camera it
is the biggest disappointment of the
entire phone I'll go ahead and say right
now the biggest was disappointing
problem on the Moto X is the camera the
RGB clear pattern layout is supposed to
be better for taking in low-light shots
and getting in more light for faster
shutter speeds and it does do that and
that actually does work for getting more
light but overall the pictures that it
takes were extremely extremely
disappointing you can activate the
camera UI pretty quickly with a quick
double rotation about its axis so that's
a nice shortcut and
to get into the camera UI which is
pretty simple again targeting iPhone
users and the average people with this
one but it's at least decent looking
it's also really simple I think my
problem with the UI was that it was a
little bit too simple like there's no
way to select metering so you just kind
of have to trust that the phone gets the
brightness right but it's not always
trustworthy if you have a very dark and
a very light subject in the same frame
but otherwise all the other controls are
pretty easy to get to with a couple of
swipe gestures but the picture quality
itself and not good I would out
characterize these shots I took with it
as muted and soft muted with the colors
and soft in the sharpness department
just very very consistently soft every
time trust me I check to see if there
was still the plastic over the lens so
many times it's not the pictures I they
really are consistently this soft when
compared to other smartphones and it's
even more noticeable when you compare it
to something like the iPhone 5 or the
galaxy s4 now it's fortunate that at
least this is camera firmware so the
camera firmware and the image processing
are something that can be updated via
and over-the-air update so in theory
Motorola could fix this with a quick
software upgrade anytime they want but
for now that is the biggest
disappointment for me in the Moto X and
then there are you know little things
like the software feeling slightly
unfinished maybe a bit rushed
you know the 18 t model I have has this
weird random gap in the notification bar
every time I'm on Wi-Fi and when you
turn the quick toggle sideways they get
a little weird and they don't take up
all the space and even that translucent
on screen navigation bar at the bottom
while I like that it's really good it's
also pretty inconsistent and they're
sometimes they're clear sometimes
they're black
again if Motorola is listening these
things can be fixed with software
updates but right now they are the
biggest complaints also about the
speaker on the back it's crisp and loud
but it's also quite small and can easily
be muted with a poorly misplaced finger
check this out
you know what
beyond all its little minor shortcomings
I really love using the Moto X it's been
one of my favorite phones to mess around
with in a long time and it's about the
experience and it definitely delivers
way beyond what a lot of us expected it
to when we looked at the specs you know
thin bezels lovely typing experience
nice compact design sharp crisp bright
colorful display a great performer it's
just a lot of fun in a little box and
it's probably perfect for someone coming
from an iPhone or any first-time Android
user and on top of all of that on top of
everything we just talked about this
phone has a customizable look this is a
massive differentiator that's just like
icing on the cake for this devices
appeal you can pick your back color
there's a ton of those your front can be
black or white and you can pick the trim
color that goes around the camera ring
and volume buttons so you can for the
first time really make this device your
own and get it to your doorstep in the
United States in just four days starting
in September so fingers crossed for
international availability ASAP we know
it's coming it's just a matter of when
so in the end the Moto X is definitely a
really nice phone especially to use and
to hold it definitely feels really great
in the hand and for this reason this is
going to be a phone that I recommend a
lot of people who are using Android for
the first time switchers from the iPhone
from windows phones from blackberries
from other smaller phones because this
is incredibly easy for them to get used
to in terms of size and in terms of
functionality because this is stock pure
Android and it will likely be getting
Android 4.3 pretty soon and even if it's
not appealing to us geeks us pixel
junkies who love the bigger display of
the galaxy note 2 and the note three
soon and all kinds of other incredibly
high-end specs and processing power even
if it's not appealing to all of us I
think this phone is going to sell better
than a lot of other devices we've seen
recently and I think it's a pretty
awesome first step in the collaboration
between Google and Motorola so either
way that's been the Moto X review I hope
you enjoyed it feel free to share this
around with your friends I spent a lot
of time on this review video so if you
have any other questions that I missed
there's a comment section open right
below that like button for you to just
open up
just tell us about what you need to know
about the motox I'll answer it there and
also if you want to see more videos like
this there's a subscribe button below
for you too and hopefully you'll be able
to get more videos in the future either
way thanks for watching now talk to you
guys in the next video
you